go ahead
hey book uh first of all i see your you
got another throwback
sun's shirt on so just between that
between the shirt you wore the other day
just how are you
how are you getting these looks who's
who's helping you you get these t-shirts
we're just finding them you know what
i'm saying you go outside you go down
the street
all those tents set up you go you go
snag them up
but i'm just paying my dues honestly you
know i'm saying this is a basketball
town
and these guys put in the work to for
the arena to be as loud as it was
last night so
you know i appreciate every everybody on
this shirt for making this organization
what it is
on a different topic i remember after
one of the clippers games you and chris
were in the room at the same time and
you were kind of
lamenting or reminiscing about early in
the season when monty was like
we got the worst starting five in the
league and we need to figure some things
out and you said that you and chris
did sit down and talk about some things
just what do you remember about those
conversations and what you guys sort of
did
figure out and and how quickly do you
feel like you figured it out that sort
of has launched what what the season has
become
um we sat down it wasn't just me and
chris is the whole starting five
um and we're just really honest with
each other and
you know i always say we hang our hang
our head on the defensive end
and that's where most of the
conversation was you know we
we obviously have to figure out a
chemistry on the offense end and
how we're going to move and what pace
we're going to move at but
you know if we're not going to be
scoring the other team can't be scoring
either
and those conversations all those bits
and pieces all those moments
you know i think are you know why we're
in the position we're in right now
um but you know we still still have to
get the job done
dwayne wanted to ask are you asking your
dad about the guys on the shirts
i was just talking to julie about him
julie's been here julia's with all these
guys
but now i've i've watched i've done my
research
okay i'm just i'm just checking because
the the shirt looks a lot newer than
what it should
i've done a lot of research it was well
kept yeah okay
those are the ones you gotta find quick
follow though um just curious about
finding roles each guy when did you
start
seeing that not necessarily yourself but
other guys were starting to accept
or embrace their roles at what point in
the season did you see that
formulating um i talked about that east
coast road trip that we went on
um i think those that was a heavy hitter
lineup for us where
and i wouldn't say everybody found their
role but
you know we came together um more than
ever at that time and understanding that
you know if we want to get done what we
got to get done that
you know we're all going to have to
sacrifice something um
and i think every great team has to do
that
devin um two-part question here uh monty
has been praising you recently about
when you guys first met when he got the
job that you were telling him that he'd
be open to whatever he wants
or he wants you to do so two-parter here
what do you recall about that meeting
what do you think monty's
overall impact has been on the group
yeah i think it was a day after
um he became the head coach who went to
dinner
we were just chopping it up and ours
told them
whatever it takes you know i've never
had a problem with any coach i've ever
had in since grade school
so just let me know what i got to do let
me know what i got to do better at
be be honest with me and
you know i'm gonna go do that to the
best of my ability
and you know that i think that was the
start of us form in this
environment that we live in that that we
get better in every day now
just having that relationship with coach
the open dialogue communication
him understanding where we come from as
as players
also helps that out a lot um
and yeah you know that that's what we
live on you know the energy in our gym
the culture that we're around
um and i think that's why we've you know
continued to trend
in the right direction as the year went
on ahead sam
devin you've talked about kobe a lot and
the impact he had on you
to steal a phrase from you know he had a
documentary called muse where he talked
about
everything that shaped him i just wonder
from kobe to the other
folks who played a part in shaping your
game who was it for you
when it when you figured out who you
wanted to be as a player and the way you
moved
in this space beyond kobe who comes to
mind rip hamilton
and i actually got the chance when i
broke my nose to have
you know a short conversation with him
and we've we've talked in the past but
you know that was my childhood hero that
whole team honestly even playing against
the clippers last series and
big shot bill up sitting over there on
on the bench you know that's
that's an inspiration for me that those
moments there even just by looking at
chauncey on the sideline like
will lock me back in immediately
so there's tons of guys honestly but
if i we're talking one it's you know my
my piston guys for sure
hey devin um but you know
demographically phoenix has a large
latino population and
you know i'm wondering what that's been
like for you given your background
connecting with that
with that side of your past and then
you know what are some of the ways
you've explored that while you've been
here
i'm around it every day you know i
always say you know i'm fortunate enough
to
to live around the scene in the stand
seeing it around the city and
you know growing up in grand rapids
michigan you don't get as much of it
um besides the time that i spent with my
grandpa and my mother
what she's passed down to us but living
around it in the culture and good to see
in a day-to-day
you know is is a lot better and being
able to touch those type of communities
in this area makes all this that much
better
a book congratulations on the nba cares
award when you announced
the starting five at the start what's it
like now two years into it to seeing
everything come to fruition and knowing
the impact that's going to have beyond
now
this is my favorite part it's my
favorite part
you know i don't i don't care for much
recognition
anything anything else that i do and
you know i don't do it for the
recognition but i'm glad that
you know the foundation is getting this
type of light and this type of exposure
because it means a lot it means a lot to
this community it means a lot to my
family
means a lot to my brother being on the
board at phoenix suns charities
it's what we get the most excited about
so you know for us to win that award
you know i wouldn't say for me to win it
for phoenix sons charities for
the whole foundation to win that award
is is really important to us
dave look there was a tweet that was
going around last night where
it said you never scored 20 at kentucky
you only had
10 shot attempts four times you go from
that to a guy who scores 70 in a game to
now who's
dropping 27 in the nba finals did you
did it cost you any doubt back in
college
no i just know it was that coach
calipari guy
[Laughter]
no um what i said earlier you know every
great team has to have sacrifices and i
don't think
you know this might have happened once
or twice but a team that talented
you know that many guys that many nba
guys and
in one practice gym to even make it work
as well as coach cow did with the whole
platooning system was
incredible so we all had to buy in we
all had to sacrifice and just
understanding our role i mean carl towns
didn't leave the paint
he never left the paint coach i remember
vividly practices were
carl would shoot at three and coach cal
loses mind and
now he's a forty percent seven foot
shooter
um so just understanding that you know
understanding and adjusting and
you know what can i do to to help this
team win and
you know that was my role there you know
i think i only ran like four
pick-and-rolls my whole
my whole college career but you know it
got us in the position to
to get where we needed her to go does
that apply to the talent of this group
but the death of talent yeah you know
there's guys sacrificing
um and that's all of us you know
everybody
everybody can play everybody's hoopers
and even the guys that aren't playing
you know playing any other team and
you know still a big part of how we
continue to grow how we continue to get
better
you know those guys understanding the
game and you know us
all respecting each other you know to
the amount to where
you know people can come to you with
open dialogue and let you know when
you're not doing what you're supposed to
do